today we're talking about supermassive's
new game that sounds way too scary for
will meet
supermassive has announced its next big
game the quarry and it's a teen horror
more in the line of what players saw in
until dawn in fact creative director
will biles who also directed until dawn
says that the quarry is something of a
spiritual successor to that game and it
looks to be supermassive's most
ambitious game yet the game focuses on a
group of nine counselors hanging out at
hatchet's quarry summer camp on the last
day of the season the campers are gone
and the obligations are fulfilled so the
teens are left to their own devices and
take the opportunity to party in the
woods the trailer has a few hints about
the overall tale that the quarry will
tell but does give impressions of a lot
of different possible trajectories the
quarry is also set to further expand
supermassive's multiplayer approach to
its interactive movie style games while
there are a lot of people who like super
massive games for uncovering the story
and challenge of survival there's also a
big audience of people who enjoy them as
experiences they watch rather than play
or participate in on a less intensive
level the quarry supports up to seven
players with online co-op as well as its
couch co-op offerings bile said that if
you own the game you can host online
play sessions with others who only have
the quarry's demo version allowing them
to watch the story as you play it and
vote on choices along the way there's
also a movie only version where you can
set a variety of parameters like
character personality traits and then
just sit back and watch the story play
out alone or with friends but biles
noted if you feel like jumping into the
interactive version of the game you can
stop the movie at any point and take
control the corey is set to launch on
june 10th on ps4 5 xbox series x s and 1
and pc and in other horrifying news
thomas the tank engine has arrived in
eldon ring the children's tv icon has
been modded into all sorts of games and
now he can appear right in the middle of
the lance between the tree's sentinel
thomas mod replaces the optional limb
grave boss with thomas's smiling face or
at least the lower half of the sentinel
the result is something like a centaur
if centaurs had happy trains as their
bottom halves you can find the mod on
nexus mods if you want to try it out for
yourself but as always use the mods at
your own risk and in other elden ring
news less than a month after it was
released the game has sold over 12
million units so far according to bandai
namco that number accounts for both
digital sales and shipments of physical
additions to retailers but not
necessarily yet sold through to
consumers on playstation 4 and
playstation 5 elden ring was the
playstation store's most downloaded game
in february alone and now hit the
comment section and let me know why do
you like scary things why why just sell
me on it
why